the fastest way to accomplish anything
is to model someone who has already had
the same success that you are after you
can go around trying to figure out
everything by yourself trying to come up
with every new idea yourself and you
will slowly slowly make progress towards
your ideas but until you recognize that
success leaves clues that whatever the
thing is that you're trying to
accomplish has already been solved by
thousands of people that all you need to
do is model the success Until you
realize that you're gonna constantly say
struggling making slow progress knowing
that you're capable of more so I first
learned the power of my own success with
my first business I was 1920 not making
any money 300 bucks a month low
confidence filled with self-doubt not
getting results and I told my partner
that I quit and the thing that saved me
when I hit my lowest point was I am not
the first person to try to solve this
problem before maybe my specific
scenario yes biotech software you know
from Toronto who's done that before
nobody but a software company get into a
million dollars somebody's done that
before how about I just look at their
success and try to emulate it need
motivation watch your top 10 with
believe Nation hey it's Nina Carmichael
we made this video it's probably because
you're the most ambitious person in your
circle you know you're capable of more
and you get that punch by surround
yourself with the best so today let's
learn from one of the best my husband
Aaron Carmichael and his top 10 rules
for success
so I first learned the power of violent
success with my first business where I
was struggling I was I was 19 20. I'm
not making any money 300 bucks a month
low confidence filled with self-doubt
not getting results you know I turned
down high paying jobs to do this thing
and own 30 of a company that seemed to
be going nowhere and I told my partner
that I quit and the thing that saved me
when I hit my lowest point was I am not
the first person to try to solve this
problem before maybe my specific
scenario yes biotech software you know
from Toronto who's done that before
nobody but a software company get into a
million dollars somebody's done that
before
how about I just look at their success
and try to emulate it and so the only
person I could think of off the top of
my head was Bill Gates so I looked at
Bill Gates and how it got started and it
was through Partnerships and I applied
that lesson to my business and in a
short amount of time had my first deal
for thirteen and a half thousand dollars
I felt like a rich man you know I felt
like holy cow and to go from 300 bucks a
month and and saying I quit to now
having a deal in place for 13 and a half
K and more important the strategy that I
could use again and again again was was
life-changing for me
all because I modeled success and that
was again when I was 1920 so now what
have I done for the past 20 years is
just model success what is my YouTube
channel about what is this video about a
lot of success why have these people
behind me it's not for you it's for me I
want to model success they're constantly
pulling me up to a greater spot whatever
problem you have has been solved not
exactly the specific minutia but by
modeling Bill Gates it took me 80 of the
way
you still have to figure out that final
20 but most people are trying to figure
out the whole hundred that's the problem
I was struggling when I was trying to
figure out the whole hundred all by
myself I just come up coming up with new
ideas new ways new innovation but
nothing worked
all you have to do is figure out that
last 20 and so look to your Heroes look
to potential mentors whether you know
them in person or not they've done it
before they can teach you success leaves
Clues you don't have to go through this
alone and you can ramp up your success
really quickly rule number two fix your
thinking how you think about the problem
is the problem most people are locked
into losing thinking finding all the
reasons why you won't win if you're the
ant think about how you can kill the
elephant if you're the elephant think
about how you can kill the ant the
problem is not the problem how you think
about the problem is the problem so I
used to think that introverts couldn't
win I used to think that to be a good
speaker to have a YouTube channel to to
be an entrepreneur that introverts can't
win and for the longest time I hid
behind the faces on my website so before
even starting YouTube I started on my
website it was called devincharmacle.com
I didn't have a better name at the time
and I profiled different successful
entrepreneurs basically what I do on
YouTube but on my website because I
wanted to share the stories model and
success saved my business and I wanted
to make it easier for other people to be
able to get success on their own as well
so learn who's done it apply those
strategies make it work for you and
let's go and so I always hid behind the
faces I remember my first banner I had
Howard Hughes a big Howard Hughes uh
Oprah Winfrey and a couple of people and
people kept asking me well where is Evan
Carmichael you know the website's off
your name you're putting this together
what's your story and I thought well who
cares about my story I mean sure I built
and sold my first business but it's
nothing compared to how we're Hughes and
Oprah Winfrey's people have done great
things and it kept coming up over and
over and over again translate that to my
YouTube channel Evan Carmichael was
still the number one requested top ten
and when I first started doing top tens
we did Kanye West shout out to Kanye
there on the wall and then a bunch of
other people people kept asking for mine
like well what do you want mine you mean
again what have I done compared to Kanye
West and I always hid behind the fact
that I was an introvert and so I don't
want to share my story nobody is
interested I'm shy I'm I'm the
Wallflower I don't go off and try to
make myself the center of attention I
don't like you know hanging out with
people and so I had the story that
introverts Can't Win It wasn't until I
reframed it and thought you know what
introverts can win
in Communications because we're better
listeners I'm a great listener as much
as you might think I love talking and
making these videos and seeing the
speeches that I do what I love doing
more than that is listening and I think
that's how you win as an introvert
because it's not about you just sharing
sharing sharing talk talk look at me
it's you're trying to help and I've met
some amazing introverts who are on a
huge Mission and why not have a big
impact and have to fight with themselves
to get out of the comfort zone and have
the spotlight on them instead of just
being behind the scenes but they're all
great listeners they become great
communicators because they're great
listeners and so the problem wasn't that
I'm an introvert the problem is how I
thought about the problem of being an
introvert rule number three take control
of your this missions every time you say
I can't you're teaching yourself that
you suck because you've quit because
you've given up it's not your fault that
you can't do it it's your work or your
school or your family or all the other
commitments that you have but not your
fault nope
nope
nope
change your I can't to either I'm going
to or I choose not to that's how you
take back control of your decisions and
your life so I recently listened to this
Chinese song and I got obsessed with it
I got obsessed with it I was playing it
all day long and I just I loved I don't
know what they're saying I don't know
which I don't know what the words mean I
just love I loved it I loved it I go to
bed
and lyrics start coming to me rap lyrics
in full sentences right the first one
comes in okay wake up I'm in bed I'm
lying in bed trying to sleep you know
it's 11 o'clock trying to sleep constant
idea rap lyric come okay I write it down
again Rattlers come write it down more
and more and more write it down until
three in the morning I haven't slept yet
ideas just keep coming for this song
that's like I need to make a rap
and then what comes into my head is that
what you can make a wrap
it's easy to get locked in into I can't
mode I can't do this I can't start that
I can't do a rap I didn't go to school
for that not that you go to school for
rap you know I didn't rap growing up I
don't have musical Talent right that's
not what people know me for that's how
people expect from me I can't rap
foreign
that's where most people quit
but instead I decided I was gonna get up
at three something in the morning go to
my computer finish writing out my lyrics
and then I spent the day rapping and
that night finished the video sent it
off to uh Christina my Editor to put it
together and the next day we released my
rap video now maybe you love it maybe
you hate it it's gotten some decent
responses it was tons of fun to put
together and most importantly I taught
myself in all of these things these are
all great micro moments to teach
yourself that you're amazing
whenever you say I can't and you do it
that's how you build self-confidence
that's that's the birthplace of
self-confidence self-love self-respect
is taking something that you think that
you can't do and just trying
not even doing it full out because I
don't expect my rap to go off and win
any kind of awards right but I tried it
I did it I released it expect the second
beginning that's okay it's normal it's
part of the process but in those moments
of I can't and then turning them into
something that actually exists
is where your Genius will come
I look at my top 10 series and partly
why I have Kanye on my wall because the
first video that I made was on Kanye
first top 10 was on Kanye was five years
into my YouTube career
I did a response to my friend Mark
Draeger
from Phantom media and I said initially
I can't do this like I can't make a
video now on this I have all these other
commitments I have a full day ahead of
other stuff that I'm supposed to do and
said no I did action I'm just gonna do
it forget it I'm gonna make it and I
didn't expect it to do well
luckily it actually did and then that
became this whole thing of making I
don't know how many top tens hundreds
maybe a thousand I don't know how many
top ten how many times have I done I
have no idea
but it started off as this idea
trust your ideas know that they're
amazing
stop saying I can't to yourself this is
where you need to take control of your
head and your heart you have to make
decisions with your heart and then use
your head to figure out how to do it
anytime you're doing something new super
important anytime you're doing something
new I'm making I'm gonna make a rap I'm
gonna make a top 10 video I'm gonna do
anything outside my normal thing right
same for you anytime you're doing
something new it doesn't make sense
because it's new what is brand new
doesn't make sense you're creating
something new and so your head your
logical brain that's designed to keep
you safe doesn't understand it its job
is to to protect you and says don't do
that
you can't do that
because one has ever been done and
because we have all these reasons why
it's not possible for you not just
anybody else for you that you can't do
it because you haven't done it before
that's what your head says your heart
can create something new your heart
creates art your heart makes up a world
that hasn't existed before and so at the
very beginning of many projects you're
having your heart or against each other
your heart's saying I want to make this
your hearts think you can't make this
and so you end up staying stuck in limbo
with all these ideas never taking
momentum because you're you're heading
your heart are fighting you've got your
foot on the gas and the break at the
same time never moving knowing that
you're capable of more and so you make
the big decisions in your life with your
heart and then you rally your head to
say okay we're doing this I'm making the
rap video I'm making the top ten you're
gonna do your crazy idea and then your
head says ooh okay they're serious let's
figure out how not to die doing this
right let's figure out how to actually
make it work
so you make the big decisions in life
with the heart and then you use your
head to figure out how to go out and
accomplish it rule number four learn to
reframe
change how you feel
the problem is most of the time we don't
catch our feelings if you're feeling
negative angry frustrated depressed it
doesn't matter what the thing is that
you're trying to accomplish you're not
going to give it your all and you're not
going to get results because of your
negative emotional state if you don't
start changing how you feel you're never
going to make progress on the goals that
you set for yourself so one of the
things I love doing whenever faced in a
negative situation is say it's the best
it's the best I'm wearing this hat says
Fanta because friend of the channel Mark
Drigger pointed out to me when I was
saying it's the best that I'm a reframer
I'm reframing I've never heard of the
concept before reframing means you take
this negative situation and then you
spin it you reframe it so that it's
positive so that it motivates you so
that's exciting so that it pushes you
forward instead of it being a negative
thing that is all encompassing and
depressing and brings you down and he
said well you're always positive because
you're just a reframer and it he has his
anagram and I'm a number six or
something I don't know he can give you
more details you want to know what
number you are and what it means go
follow mark.rag on Instagram and ask him
but
I think that's something
everybody can learn how to reframe you
take whatever negative situation that's
in front of you and say this is the best
right now this is the best where this
came from was I was on a airplane from
Vancouver to Los Angeles and that's a
five hour flight give or take and I have
to sit next to this really smelly dude
and there was no other option I had to
stay on the plane I had to make my
flight I had to speak at this event the
only other option was get off the plane
and it was really smelly I'm sure he
didn't want to be smelly I'm sure that
wasn't his you know intention or
ambition it just happened probably had
three stopovers you know I hadn't
showered in in however long and just
he's stuck and in my head I'm trying to
find Solutions there's no Solutions and
so I'm upset I'm complaining you know
the 15 seconds of back and forth this
sucks I can't believe it and then here's
what happens in my head I say this is
the best this negative thing that's in
front of me right now this is the best
this is my chance to show myself what
I'm made of right and so he's sitting
right here next to me I'll look over
and just breathe it in breathe that in
breathe in that smell breathe it in
to show myself
that this is not
that this one dude is not going to ruin
my day and I feel great now about myself
because self-confidence comes from doing
difficult things and I just did
something difficult and that's where
it's the best came from it was a it was
a quick trigger to myself to say this is
the best it's the best and now it's
become this thing that anytime I'm faced
in a really negative situation that
feels overwhelming and possible just
want to complain find somebody to blame
and say it's your fault no this is the
best this is my chance to show myself
and the world what I am made of and so
you can flip it for yourself what is so
overwhelming so impossible so crazy that
is bringing you down you look at your
calendar you look at your list of emails
and it's just depressing great this is
the best if you believe like I believe
that your purpose comes from your pain
if you believe that the thing that you
struggled with the most in life becomes
your calling for the rest of your life
the time that you struggled and suffered
the most as a human your your purpose
for the rest of your life is to help
other people who currently are who you
used to be then that thing that happened
that that massively negative thing the
most painful moment in your life
actually is the best
because it's going to allow you to serve
hundreds thousands maybe millions of
people through your purpose so that
negative thing's in front of you tell
yourself it's the best also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five change your
calendar most people have not taken
control of their schedules you wake up
like an accident start responding to
other people's emergencies and and help
other people build their dreams instead
of you building yours it's time for a
change you deserve better and this video
is going to show you how I think one of
the biggest reasons why so many
entrepreneurs don't take enough action
is because when you get motivated you
don't do enough you feel the motivation
you feel the boldness feel the
confidence but you're not taking enough
action you're not doing enough I
remember going to my first Tony Robbins
event this is before uh I knew Tony
one-on-one before I did the interview
with him on my channel I just went to
see what would the event be like I've
I've seen so many different videos of so
many different people and I felt like
you know what for most people going to
their event it'd probably be the same as
just watching on YouTube but for Tony I
felt you know what I think his event
might be different there's something
that tells me by going to his event
it'll be different than what I just see
on YouTube through the content and so I
went I went with my wife I went with
three people on my team I paid for
everyone to go out and went to our first
Tony Robbins event
and at the end of the last day if you've
never been to Tony Robbins event it's on
fire you're you're motivated you're
jumping you're dancing you're hugging
you're high-fiving you're you're
breaking through limits it's it's
amazing by the end of the last day you
see everybody in the streets you're
pouring out everybody's all pumped up
and energized like I'm gonna do this I'm
gonna do that
I remember one of the people that I
brought with me he's like yeah I'm gonna
do all this stuff and he's like yelling
and so fired up and excited he's like
what are you doing Evan like I'm looking
at my calendar
because
this is why so many people fall off you
go to an event like that and then you
fall off because you're not making a
consistent success is habits so whenever
you decide to make a change you have to
at least for me I look immediately to my
calendar
so if my goal is now I want to be a big
YouTuber great when am I going to make
videos it's got to be in the calendar
it's not in the calendar it's never
going to happen and so anytime you want
to make a meaningful change you have the
default of thinking what am I going to
put into my calendar because success is
habits and so it's great to be motivated
maybe these videos do it for you maybe
Events maybe books podcasts awesome
you're getting it from somewhere you
feel motivated great show me in your
calendar where you are spending the time
to actually make the thing happen
otherwise you're just living off some
fumes you know you get motivated for a
day or two it feels amazing and then you
fall back down to normal if you want
that dream life you want that next step
for yourself it's gonna come from
changing your habits changing what's in
your calendar to make sure that what you
say you want out of life you're actually
working towards making that happen rule
number six build trust if you want to
become a millionaire or influence a
million people you need to learn to
build trust this is where you can really
win as an entrepreneur because people
have a really hard time trusting big
companies to do the right thing so this
is where you win
you win by not trying to be exactly like
the big companies you win by showing
that you actually care and will do the
right thing by the customer so bringing
it to a YouTube world as an example I
think everybody should be responding to
all comments one of the things that I
believe in is every comment we try to
get a response to every comment gets a
response every comment gets a response
and at the beginning when you're doing a
YouTube channel it's easy my first video
on YouTube it took me a year to get
three comments I made a video within one
year there were only three comments on
that video the first comment was my mom
thank you Mom the second comment was my
older sister thank you Alexandra and the
third comment was from some random dude
a new somebody discovered my channel
right one year three comments those are
pretty easy to respond to right it's
super easy in the early days when you're
not getting comrades if you're getting a
comment a day a comment a week couple
comments a day it's easy to respond to
what happens when people's scale is they
stop responding to comments because they
don't know how to scale the business
because at the beginning they're doing
everything themselves and it doesn't
take up a lot of time but as you start
getting more comments it starts to take
up more time I get hundreds of comments
every day on my on my YouTube channel I
can't respond to every single comment
personally myself
if I could I could if I did it then I
wouldn't do anything else I'm gonna be
making this video because I was spending
all my time responding to people's
comments right that's the process but
just like any other business when you
start a business you're doing everything
yourself if you start selling flowers on
the street you're doing everything right
you got to find the flowers you got to
sell the flowers you got to distribute
the flowers you're doing everything
as you grow and as you get a flower
store then you bring on a team right and
you have people who are selling flowers
for you and open this door for you
including the store for you you're still
doing work right you're doing more
important work you can't do all of the
tasks in the business at all times if
you're always doing everything you're
never going to scale
and so I believe that bigger YouTube
channels should hire a team to respond
to comments I have an awesome guy my
team named velco so you'll see
responding to a lot of comments and
he'll save the comments that I need to
see so if there's feedback or
suggestions or improvements I want to
see them if there's criticism I want to
see it if it's just saying thank you
Evan for the video amazing I feel the
love I don't need to see all of those
comments that come in right I'll I'll
sort through some of them respond to
some of them but that's not gonna be the
best use of my time every day because
then I'm not making videos and so make
that equivalent for yourself
at the beginning it's easy to show hard
and easy to show care because you don't
have that many customers because maybe
you only have one customer and so you
can show them the love but as you scale
and grow how can you continue to do that
whether it's you doing that most
important element yourself because
that's the thing that drives it or you
have people on your team that really
show that love and support because you
want to make sure the customer feels
respected and appreciated it's really
easy to build trust in a one-on-one
situation it's harder as you build and
scale your clients and so you need to
build and skill your culture alongside
rule number seven work hard hard hard
work is your ticket in no matter where
you come from what you look like what
your skills are hard work is always the
ticket in the odds might be against you
awesome now what quit on your dreams or
keep working hard how you answer that
question will change your life so I have
an agent in New York and when I first
started the agency I almost didn't get
in uh I didn't get in because I'm a
weird case for them my agent now he
looked at me back then and this must
have been six or seven years ago by now
and he said Evan I love your message the
problem is you're not a very good
communicator and that hurt at the
beginning because I had already done
some speaking gigs I'd already been
making videos for three or four years
you know I've had hundreds if not a
thousand videos already under my belt
and here he is saying that I suck at
communicating and he said the people
that he typically works with are people
who are already in media who have tons
of experience who are great in front of
the camera they need help refining their
message
he said for you I love your message
you've got a great message you just suck
at being a little communicated like
and so okay great well where do we go
from here and he said I'm gonna take a
flyer on you
I don't normally do this I'm gonna take
a flyer on you and see where you go and
I I didn't want to waste my opportunity
I didn't even know that you could get an
agent as a as a business person as an
entrepreneur as a speaker I mean I guess
I heard a speaking houses but an agent I
thought more entertainment or Sports not
for business so I didn't want to lose
this opportunity you know I didn't want
to regret not giving it my best and so I
said okay great tell me what I need to
do I'm the worst right now awesome I I
don't have the skills that everybody
else here has how can I get better what
do I need to do tell me and he said okay
so your first challenge is I need you to
make a bio video and I need you to tell
your story a foundation Story video
make it 20 to 40 minutes long and record
it and I'm gonna look at it and I'm
going to give you my feedback on it okay
great so I recorded it the next day and
it was in the morning and recorded it
sent it to him he gave me feedback
and then at lunch I recorded it again he
gave me feedback I recorded again in the
evening I did it 30 to 40 times that's a
lot over over the course of how many
days you know 10 to 12 days I guess uh I
recorded the video over and over and
over and over and over and over and over
again every time you give me feedback I
do it again feedback do it again
and I got better and I got better and
over the course of a couple months
when I was making three videos a day
practicing sucking but just practicing
and trying to get better and listening
to feedback and trying to improve I
quickly became the best case at the
agency I quickly became the number one
person from from views from subscribers
from Best Practices I copy what Evan's
doing now I'm being brought on to help
them with their clients and train some
of them on how they can get better on
YouTube and build their brand from being
the worst from the guy who almost didn't
get in
because the people who are joining them
one maybe had bigger egos but also we're
having a hard time finding the time to
make a video a week
and if they're not making a video a week
or having a hard time doing it and I'm
making three a day even if I suck I'm
gonna get better I'm gonna outpace just
because I'm willing to work just because
I'm putting in the effort you might not
have the skills you might not have the
talent you might not have the looks you
might not have what you think you need
to have
how does an introvert
build a huge audience and and spread a
huge message and be famous on YouTube I
don't know I mean I'm working on it join
me on my journey we'll figure it out
together
that was my agent's concern when I first
got started and I'm I'm breaking the
mold and doing things in the way that
haven't been done and you can do the
same thing
through hard work hard work doesn't
guarantee your success there's a lot of
people who work really hard and never
win a lot of people who work 12-hour
days and are doing minimum wage jobs
they're working hard and they don't win
you have to work hard and you have to
work smart but it's not one or the other
the people who were in The Agency were
working smart but we're making one video
a week
I was working less smart
but making three videos a day so I'm
gonna get better I'm gonna get smarter
I'm gonna make it faster I'm gonna I'm
gonna show you what I can do
hard work is always your ticket in and
one of the biggest problems that people
just aren't working either hard enough
or smart enough
just want it too soon and you can be
impatient and it's amazing but better
than being impatient with the results is
being impatient with yourself
most people are impatient with the
results like it's not coming fast enough
like where are my subscribers or My
Views it's not happening my first video
took me a year to get three comments and
the first one was my mom the second one
was my sister and the third was some
random dude right a year to get three
comments and two of the people were my
family
you're impatient with the results what
you should be is impatient with yourself
when you're not getting results when
it's not happening
audit yourself are you putting in the
work are you doing enough work are you
working smart enough are you applying
the right strategies get more frustrated
with yourself and your effort more than
that the results aren't there because if
you woke up every day and did that
equivalent of making three videos a day
when other people are making one video a
week you will eventually win it might be
slower than you'd like but it's always
slower than you'd like but you will
eventually win because hard work is
always your ticket in ruin them hey
develop new skills you will never lose
in life if you have valuable skills you
won't lose your house you won't lose
your car you won't lose your clients if
you have a skill that brings people
value the economy can collapse the
algorithms can change but as long as you
have a skill that solves problems for
people you will be safe so I'm seeing
this a lot in the YouTube world now I
have a new course out helping people get
to a million subscribers on YouTube we
can link up the description there if you
want in and people are saying well
should I still do YouTube is it too late
like YouTube won't be here in five years
or 10 years or maybe it's gonna be the
next thing that should hop on it's not
about the platform like right now it's
winning the platform that is currently
winning you need to crush it right like
YouTube should be your home if you're
trying to make an impact you're trying
to be a thought leader you have a
message to spread YouTube has to be your
number one place it just has to be right
now otherwise you're not making a smart
decision but whether YouTube is still
around in 20 years five years doesn't
matter because the skill set that you
learn you can take anywhere the ability
to communicate you could take to any
platform you could take to the next
thing I don't anticipate YouTube still
being around in 20 years but my ability
to make videos talking to a lens
that's not gonna go away that can serve
me for life right whether that's VR Evan
or hologram Evan you know coming into
your living room that's that's gonna be
me that's gonna be amazing I'm pumped I
look forward to it
any algorithm change that people are
freaking out about anybody who's
complaining about the economy going down
or the algorithm changing you've already
lost that's a losing mindset when I was
first starting my YouTube channel
uh I always saw the algorithm as a
chance to win right you should see if
you're a small Creator on any platform
YouTube Instagram anything and the
algorithm shifts that's your greatest
Advantage you should be cheering you
should want more algorithm changes if
you look at a traditional established
boring Market uh it's hard to win real
estate could be hard to win right
financial markets can be hard to win not
that it's not possible it's just hard to
win because there's a lot of people who
have who have Decades of experience and
no more than you and it's hard to close
that gap of experience
with social media with YouTube every
time there's a big algorithm change the
people who are experts at the last thing
they're crying instead of adjusting
that's how you win that's how you get
ahead of them that's how you become the
top dog is because you're gonna go learn
the new algorithm when everybody is
wishing and hoping that the old
algorithm comes back and this happens
for every platform that happened for
Facebook every time they change your
algorithm or updated the the feed and
what was shown there people always freak
out and complain and they sign they want
petitions and like let's go back to how
it used to be don't sign those petitions
don't jump on that penguin that is loser
thinking never ever ever ever ever ever
ever do that it's loser thinking and
that's how most people think
that's a mindset shift that I want to
make for the collective but more
importantly for you
that whenever there's a big change
embrace it go all in on it learn it
that's how you're going to LeapFrog
everybody else so the faster the rate of
change the more you should be cheering I
still get pumped for an algorithm change
me I mean now I'm at now I'm closer to
the top right I mean I don't know what
the top is I got two million subscribers
and 300 million views and all these
channels I still love it anytime an
algorithm change comes out I'm still
pumped train yourself Like A change is
coming I'm pumped get excited because
there's still people who are ahead of me
or even the people below me that I'm
competing with for for attention and for
space if they're sitting there
complaining about how it's changed and
they're dropping in their views awesome
I'll pick up those views because I'm
going to learn what the new algorithm is
all about
same thing with the economy when the
economy crashes everybody who's
complaining about how it used to be
they're not going to win it's comforted
in the join a club and wish things could
be how they used to be but we're not
going back to that
So the faster you realize that and make
improvements the faster you can learn
and actually build a great business some
of the greatest businesses in the world
are built in recession in depression
that could be you if you decide to be
let's hop back to skills for a second I
look at Jake Paul Logan Paul they
started on Vine right Vine was was their
claim to fame they had tons of success
in making these super short videos Vine
gets shut down right boom gone this is
don't put all your eggs in one basket I
think that's loser thinking too it's
loser thinking
they went all in on Vine and and then
Vine got shut down oh no what did they
do they moved to YouTube and started
crushing it millions of subscribers look
at their growth on YouTube over the past
I don't know two years three years blew
up why
didn't just come out of nowhere they had
the skill set they had the skill set
that they learned from doing the thing
right the skill set to make a good video
they then brought to a new platform if
YouTube goes away
you're learning the skill set of how to
communicate how to make great videos
that whatever comes next
people are freaking out about the FTC
coming in and Kappa on YouTube okay so
if kids aren't able to get content on
YouTube where they gonna go go be there
instead of trying to fight
what is already happening
go be at the place where the kids are
going to be
embrace the change
that's where you that's where you can
win what everybody else is fighting and
angry and screaming and yelling and
complaining and wishing that it used to
be or quitting the platform and getting
upset go be where they're gonna be it's
it's easy it's a simple win most people
don't have that mindset it's why most
people lose why most businesses can
evolve most most businesses shut down
it's people very rarely transition from
one platform to another from one
business to another even though they
have the skill sets and capabilities to
do so because they don't have the
mindset to do so people who crushed
Myspace very few of them are still
around
on different platforms look at look at
Hollywood the rock is doing it Will
Smith is doing it moving from Hollywood
films to YouTube where's Brad Pitt
where's George Clooney like they're in a
dine industry they should be embracing
YouTube they don't want to they have the
skills they have the skills it's
transferable you don't think George
Clooney could come in and Crush YouTube
if you wanted to
of course he could calling you out
George Clooney let's go make it happen
all right it's just about picking up the
skill set that will keep you safe in any
environment but it's also having a
mindset to follow through and try the
new things that I'm complaining about
the changes that are currently happening
Rule Number Nine stop complaining the
easiest way to win is to do work that
you love making a new video is easy for
me I've done 6 000 plus videos I still
love them and still enjoy it but there
is a chandelier sitting in the trunk of
my car right now that I have no interest
in installing I have I have no idea how
to install a light I have no interest in
learning how to install a light and so
I've asked my friend Mark Draeger from
Fanta to come and help install the light
for me if you're doing a business that
you don't know and that you don't love
and you think it's just going to be easy
money newsflash it's never just easy
money you're going to lose you have to
go through what I call the blinders test
now blinders are things that people put
on horses so there's those black patches
that they put here on the side of the
horse so the horse doesn't get
distracted so the horse isn't like going
all over like this all they can see is
what's in front of them and it forces
them to just focus and go in front of
them now side note apparently they
actually have this for humans too and
some tech companies are using them where
they have blinders for humans that seems
a little crazy to me but listen if
blinders help you focus then by all
means go for it but you need to pass the
blinders test so what is a blinders test
for me it's those moments in time
where you have absolute Clarity for what
you need to do where you know where you
want to go where you have Direction and
purpose and this is the window that you
need to jump through for me right now
it's YouTube
yes I've been on the platform for over
10 years but this is a special moment in
time for YouTube right now for Evan
Carmichael plus YouTube right now I'm
hitting it on strides we've got I don't
know how many channels right now a lot
too many maybe but I want to have a
hundred channels this is a moment in
time YouTube's not going to be around
forever and it's going to morph and it's
going to become something else and I'm
gonna have different interests at some
point this is the moment of time that
you need to then push hard I see
opportunities as Windows there's this
window that's in front of you right now
and the windows open but it's not going
to be open Forever at some point that
window of opportunity is going to shut
and that's when people look back and say
I had as I could have done it and and
that other person they made so much
money off of my idea it wasn't your idea
they did it the only difference between
you and the people who are winning is
they started they did it they take
action every single day there's no
reason why that person can't be you you
have to jump through the window with
full force and put your blinders on and
stop thinking about everything else
that's around you that's if you have
absolute Clarity and direction
now there will be other moments in your
life and I think I think life moves like
this I think you'll have moments in life
where you have absolute Clarity and
purpose and Direction and there'll be
other moments where you're not so sure
what to do
and then you have to open up the funnel
again
sticking to the blinders when you don't
know what you're doing is not a great
strategy this this happens to a lot of
entrepreneurs where they have focused
for their business but then they lose
interest in their business and then they
bought themselves a job and they're too
afraid to get out of that business
because of what it means because of the
opportunity cost because of everything
that they've they've sunk into the
business because people might say well
what a failure if they close now and
they should have been out of their
business three years ago but they're
still going don't let that be you you're
never gonna win doing work that you hate
if you don't like your business anymore
you need to adjust it or you need to
move on dump it move on to something
else if I stopped liking videos
I will just decide no more videos
happening sorry guys maybe sell it to
somebody else or just stop because I'm
not going to win doing work that I hate
either and so if you feel your foot kind
of pulling out of the water while you
still have some interest move on to the
next thing and so when you know what you
want to do you're focused hyper focused
that's all you're doing when you don't
know what you want to do you open up the
scope and that's okay and I think
everybody will go through these phases
in life you will have absolute Clarity
and so you need to go off and do instead
of finding all the reasons why you can't
do and when you don't know what you want
to do don't stress out and worry that
you don't know what you want to do try a
bunch of stuff say yes to everything pay
attention to the feeling the most
important thing when you're trying
something new is do you love the process
of it
not is this going to be your next big
opportunity did you love the price even
though you suck doing it I sucked making
my first video I love the process I
sucked when I first learned salsa
dancing I love the process you're
supposed to suck at the start that's
okay
you don't need to get instant results if
you love the process you will win if you
got instant results but you don't love
it you're never gonna win it's just
never gonna happen you're not gonna win
and so depending where you are on this
spectrum of absolute Clarity to having
no idea
dictates what your action should be when
you know what you need to do stop making
excuses stop having justifications and
just go off and do the damn thing and if
you don't know what you want to do then
explore stop feeling sorry for yourself
stop complaining it's okay explore you
will find the thing that then you can
focus on until the next time you expand
it rule number 10 love the process a
good question to ask yourself is do you
actually love this do you want it badly
enough I love making videos I sucked at
the beginning I'm still working to get
better I've gotten better over the you
know decade I've been on YouTube I still
look forward to it I still love it I
still work every week creating content
for you guys we're putting out six
videos a day across the different
channels now it's it's wild it's crazy
and I still love it we're putting in the
work I'm putting in the work my team's
putting in the work because we still
actually love the process of doing it so
so many entrepreneurs quit and give up
because you'll say you'll do whatever it
takes but you're not going to if you
don't actually love the process you
don't actually love the work you will
not do whatever it takes you will only
force yourself to do something that you
hate for so long until you give up and
quit so a big reason why entrepreneurs
don't put in enough work it's because
you just don't love it enough
if you're not happy right now it's
probably because you're not growing
humans want to grow we want to learn we
want to improve we want to get better we
want to feel like we're making
meaningful progress somewhere and when
we feel like we're learning and growing
and the work that we do matters we feel
great right if you felt great when you
learn the new skill when you when you
help somebody out when you felt that the
work you were doing was meaningful it
felt amazing
but if you have too many days in a row
or you feel like it's too hard it's too
big you're not growing you're not
learning there's
there's no hope
that leads down a really dangerous and
negative path not where we want to be
and part of why we become entrepreneurs
is because we want to grow right because
we're we don't want to have a crappy
boring job working for somebody else
wasting our talents away I remember my
my I didn't have that many jobs I had a
landscaping job which is super boring
just every day just rolling out of grass
and then I had a data entry job
where this really turned me off of the
corporate world where
I was doing the work of
we had six people five people on my team
and I was doing more work than all of
the others combined
and I didn't take lunch breaks I just I
just kept working and my boss wasn't
happy that because I was overhead
lighting gave me headaches I used to
have to bring in some snacks like food
or popcorn or carrots or something so I
didn't get crazy headaches and my boss
didn't like that I was eating a snack
while I was working
and I got in the trouble and almost got
fired
even though I was doing more work than
my entire team combined and it just
really
turned me off of the corporate world to
realize hey this is
this doesn't make any sense
I wasn't growing
you know I wasn't learning
I wasn't improving
and so you can examine your own life
if you feel like you're in a rut
chances are you haven't learned anything
recently
and so we can we can plan for this you
know you can change your schedule so
that you can focus on learning you can
put it into your daily calendar and
this is where I think it becomes the
greatest benefit my greatest tactic or
strategy for you
for myself
is schedule in learning schedule in
growing
so for me it's my own videos you know I
make these videos
hopefully for you that you learn and
improve and something Sparks for you but
I'm making for me I'm making for me
because I need it because I need to be
around people who are doing big things
and that I know that every day there's a
video for me amen it's it's going to be
positive it's going to be uplifting it's
going to spread believe it's going to be
motivational or inspiring it's going to
be Tactical
and I know that on my channel I'm going
to get content that I want
and so I've hired a whole team and built
the whole business basically around
making content that I want to watch and
thankfully enough of you guys want to
watch it as well that it it I can build
a business and have a team
but if I didn't or nobody else cared
about it I would still do it for me you
know it may not be as fancy may not have
as much intros and all that stuff but I
would still have it for me because I
need it and so
we tend to catch these things too late
because it's not part of our habits and
routines so if you notice you go to an
event or you watch a video and you get
all inspired and you're you got energy
and you're working and things are
amazing cool and then
have weeks or months gone by and you
realize what happened to me what how did
I fall off the horse
so quickly where did my energy go has
that happened to you
chances are is because it wasn't
scheduled
you know part of the entrepreneur roller
coaster is because we're bouncing from
one high to the next
without having any scheduled in learning
and growth
and so
my challenge to you would be to try to
figure out how can we schedule in
learning and growing every day
and so it starts with figuring out okay
what medium do you like the most you
know for me I like videos I like being
able to see stuff it just makes it so
much easier for me I'm a visual learner
before YouTube was a thing I learned
from books
that was the best thing available at the
time now I still have a habit of reading
10 pages at least a night but I don't
get most of my learning from books I get
most of my learning from videos but for
you maybe it's videos if you're watching
this maybe it's books maybe it's
podcasts
something like where do you get the best
learning and then the great thing about
where we are right now is there's so
much content there's so many people to
learn from there's so many people
creating
things out there that you can go and
learn from them
you know if I look at an Eric Thomas or
an Oprah Winfrey they have a similar
message just a different delivery style
and so whatever you want to learn
chances are somebody's already making
content on it
and so just go and find them and think
about who you're following right now
like do an audit of who you follow right
now we fall in on YouTube we'll be
following on Instagram or Tick Tock or
what podcasts you listen to or what
books are you picking up
and how many of those people that you're
following are subscribed to actually
make you feel
ambitious and hopeful and better about
yourself and give you strategies and
light you up and feel like you're
learning and growing right that's the
whole point of this we're trying to make
growing and learning a consistent habit
so how many people that you're following
actually make you want to learn and grow
and how many of them are you just
mindlessly scrolling through you know
when you load your Instagram or your
YouTube when you're just scrolling and
scrolling and scrolling and two hours
have gone by and
not only have you not learned anything
you feel worse about your life because
now you haven't been productive
you know you just kind of mindlessly
entertained yourself but it wasn't even
that entertaining you're like what just
happened to the past two hours of my
life has that happened to you cool
unfollow those people
it's not that they're bad people
because that content doesn't light you
up
and then start to be around the people
who do
and the easiest way is through content
so if it's my channel hey good news
we've got content every single day for
you you'll never run out of having
Chronicle content to watch but it could
be somebody else it's somebody else in
marketing or business or
entrepreneurship or person development
or whatever category you're in
to subscribe to those people and be
around them as much as possible and
watch your videos every day schedule it
in for me I go for a walk every morning
call it my believe walk I just like
getting some sun on my face and fresh
air and getting out of the home and it
just gives me some perspective and a
little bit of motion and helps me set up
my day and then I'll I'll have a video
going
from my channel
and um every morning will be somebody
else it'll be
Elon Musk or Oprah Winfrey or Mel
Robbins or Tony Robbins or garyvee or
Tom Billy or whatever and that's what we
do is pull the best clips that I would
learn from and then we share with
everybody else but that's a part of my
daily routines and I've I've seen my own
growth and development and learning and
bravery and courage and momentum and
consistency
be directly contributed and correlated
to
the content that I'm consuming daily
and so step one is to unfollow and
unsubscribe from the people who just
make you waste time feel worse about
yourself get Envy
or just mindlessly tune out
and step two then is to figure out
I need to make learning you need to make
learning growing a part of your daily
habit and so where in your calendar can
that fit
if it's over breakfast if it's a morning
walk if it's a afternoon lunch like
where in your calendar can you put
learning from your preferred Style video
podcast books Etc learning into your
daily calendar if you did that your life
will change if you did that every day
for the next year every day if you did
that if you scheduled that in and you
actually did it and you you watch your
video write a book or listen to podcasts
that inspired you said you know what I
can do this I can do more I can be more
I can accomplish This I Gotta stop
thinking small and stop doubting myself
and stop telling myself that I suck and
I can't do it I can't do this like if
you felt that energy every day from
watching a piece of content that you
intentionally put into your habits
routine every day for the next year
your life will totally transform
you will be a totally different person
which then allows you to serve more to
help more to make more money to guide
more to be a leader more all of it all
of your Ambitions and dreams everything
that you want
is all possible
but you have to factor learning and
growing into your daily consistent
habits and routine focus on one idea and
make it work focus on one business model
focus on one Revenue stream focus on one
social media Network and make it work so
many times we're focused on too many
things we're distracted and our
entrepreneur ADHD kicks in and as a
result nothing happens for all the
people who are telling you to have 13
different passive income streams because
if one goes away you still have all
these other 12 most of people who start
off doing that make zero money from all
of the passive income streams you're
making ten dollars a month four dollars
a month seven dollars a month where
instead if you could focus on one thing
and maximize it and make it amazing and
put your energy into it you will see
exponential results I look at social
media as an example and I just finished
this training where we did the seven day
built to serve challenge it was amazing
had so many awesome new thought leaders
coming to the program people have got a
big message want to serve and one of the
questions I kept getting asking is
how do I be on every social media
platform how do I be everywhere how do I
get started and just blow up everywhere
and it's like you don't right the answer
is don't don't don't try to do that
if you are the person right now who is
trying to be everywhere look at your
social media accounts
chances are you're sucking everywhere
chances are not not you suck as a human
just the results aren't there the
effort's not there the energy is not
there because you're so forcing yourself
to just get out there and create content
and be in all the platforms
that you also have a million other
things that you have to do and so as a
result you're you're creating
really mediocre content
content that people aren't interacting
with and if people don't like what
you're putting up it's not going to lead
to results for your business and so much
much much much much better it doesn't
mean that you can't be there you know
it doesn't mean that at some point you
can't be there that as you build your
brand and you get bigger and you hire a
team and you have more money that you
can start to do this but much better at
the beginning is to figure out
what is the one platform what is the one
Revenue stream what is the one business
model the one thing that if I focus on
that thing
it's going to lead to results so then I
can scale
entrepreneurs have a hard time with this
because we want to do so many things we
have our add brain going on and
we don't want to just do one thing we
also feel like it
is limiting for what we want to do right
if you have a big Vision a big mission a
giant goal for what you want to
accomplish
doing just this one little piece of it
feels too small
the way that I would structure it and
think about it is this is just a
sequence
you still get to do everything
you still get to do it all
you just have to go in order you have to
create a sequence that the thing that
you need to focus on at the beginning of
your business whether it's your Revenue
stream whether it's social media success
whatever it is what you have to figure
out is how do I start to as soon as
possible get a sustainable business for
myself
so that I can quit my job if you have
one so that I can bring income in for
myself my family so I can start to
afford to hire a team even if it's
part-time or one person so you can scale
up your company so that I can then go
off and do all the other things because
some of your ideas are are amazing and
huge and require more people and time
and effort and energy and some of the
ideas can get started a lot faster
and so if you want to go and accomplish
your big goal your big dream your big
mission then it's important to think
about the sequence of things that
instead of doing everything all at once
and as a result all of the results being
mediocre focus on the one thing that if
you push that lever you really maximize
that thing
you could start to make more money you
could start to have more impact you can
start to have more reach you can start
to see more success that then allows you
to bring on more people to help you
build and scale
for me we've got 37 people on the team
now
and
I can do so much more you know because
we got team then if it was just me by
myself doing everything and so in
building my mission I want to solve the
world's biggest problem right people
don't believe in themselves enough and
so in building that up I need people I
need help I need support I need team I
need I need a lot more than what I've
got right now
but and be able to build a business that
can bring in money then I can afford the
higher team that helps me accomplish a
lot more things and take on a lot more
projects but if I was at the very
beginning of what I was doing right now
I would not be doing most of the things
that I'm doing right now
I'd still be accomplishing and going
after the same mission
but I'd have to pick one thing to focus
on
I picked the one thing at the beginning
that I think I could make some money
doing this so that I can live I can I
can pay you know rent mortgage
I can pay my internet bills I could pay
for some food not not living you know
fancy life but just being able to live
and survive so I don't have to have a
job and then I would start thinking okay
how do I then scale this one thing that
I'm working on
to build up to the point where I can
remove myself or at least take some of
the pieces off so that I can hire a team
to help build and scale and grow if I
look back at my YouTube Journey here I
did everything at the beginning you know
I I uh I filmed it I researched it I
edited it I did all of it and it took a
crazy amount of time and I made a lot of
mistakes and I did a lot of stuff that I
probably shouldn't have done and
just by focusing on that thing and
making content and creating videos it
then allowed me to make a little bit of
money but then I could hire my first
part-time editor that then turned into a
full-time editor that turned into a
second editor and a research person that
turned into someone helping with the
thumbnails and the graphics and it
continues to build up in scale but
everything I was doing myself in a
mediocre way but getting it done
to then be able to scale out a team and
so most people are just stuck doing too
many things you start look at what
you're doing on a day-to-day basis look
at your calendar you have a limited
amount of time right you have a limited
amount of time there's only so much you
can do in in a day in a week you have
other responsibilities maybe you have a
job maybe you have a family kids health
that you have to look after you know
there's a certain amount of time that
you have that you can dedicate to this
thing that time needs to go into the
right efforts
and again it's great to have that big
mission and big goal and big dream but
if you have a limited amount of time
every day or every week
and you are
trying to create 13 passive income
streams with that limited amount of time
no one of the streams ever gets enough
energy enough effort Enough of Your Mind
space enough of your creativity Enough
of Your Love to ever become anything
and so you're diversifying way too
quickly you're diversifying way too soon
and apply that for anything that you're
working on apply that to your your
business and the and the opportunities
that you're chasing the Partnerships
that you're looking at the things that
you're saying yes to the social media
networks that you're trying to be on
do yourself a favor
don't try to be everywhere not yet
right just understand there's a sequence
to things and you can make it so much
easier for yourself to have more impact
to make more money to have a bigger
influence to be more proud of yourself
to start getting more success and more
results and more momentum so much easier
if you just sequence it out
so that you don't have to do everything
all at once you don't have to feel the
the handcuffs and the Restriction of
saying well I don't want to do this one
thing for the rest of my life this is
where it gets
you know entrepreneur Ade kicks in right
and we don't want to be locked in I
don't want to do the same thing forever
well you don't you won't do it forever
that's not the point the point is not to
do this one thing forever that if you
took these 10 opportunities in front of
you
you could do all 10. you could do all
10.
just not all 10 at the same time because
if you do all 10 at the same time none
of them are going to work out
and often it's a small opportunity that
can pay you more quickly
that can start to build the momentum for
you so if you have your list of your 10
opportunities in front of you 10 things
that you could do great look at what
order should I go in
so I can start making money and start
building momentum one last quick example
I look at a lot of thought leaders a lot
of people have a message a lot of people
want to be speakers and authors and
coaches and influencers and
they've got big goals and big Ambitions
for what they want to create
when I'm helping someone like that
usually the first option is coaching
the best thing to do at the beginning is
coaching so we're going to dive into one
specific business model right if you can
look at let's say be a speaker
uh getting brand deals as an influencer
writing a book and coaching if we had
those are four opportunities in front of
you right let's say so what did I say
being a speaker getting paid to speak
getting paid to do brand deals getting
paid to be an author and selling books
um even selling courses your own
materials and training and Etc and
coaching
those are those are you know four or
five different business models that you
can go through perfect
at the beginning
which one is the best
what should you focus on
be coaching
why
people don't like the idea of coaching
because you're trading your time for
money right I don't want to trade my
time for money okay
well what are you doing right now you
know you're at a job because if you're
at a job you're trading your time for
money
if you have unlimited time to figure
stuff out and you have you have a giant
bank account then you can do something
different but if you need to start to
make money to build this thing up then
yes you're trading your time for money
but it's a faster path to get you out of
your job and into your business
full-time
where everything else takes a lot more
time
speaking takes an incredible amount of
time if you want to if you want to be a
paid speaker and and get paid enough
that it's actually meaningful
it takes a lot of time for you to get
good at the skill as well as for you to
build up momentum in the name in the
industry you have to do a lot of free
speaking gigs before you ever get paid
to do it so if you have a horizon of
years awesome but I'd rather you start
getting paid immediately while we work
on a speaking career you want to be an
author and get paid to have a book cool
you can go and sell publish a book right
now if you wanted to you can get it out
you'll make you know you can sell it to
your friends and family your your
audience you'll make a a few bucks but
it's not going to be anything meaningful
to get a paid deal or to have a
significant even if you're going
self-publishing to make a lot of money
off your book you have to have a big
audience
to get the deal with a publisher they
want you to have at least a hundred
thousand followers that's like your
starting point to get in so is that
achievable of course but now we're
looking at years as a horizon as opposed
to like this has to happen right away so
you're not getting paid right now off of
your book so if you're sitting there
thinking right in the book creating a
great manuscript creating a great how-to
guide it's not going to be the thing
that helps get you any kind of money
anytime soon and I want you to get paid
because most people quit too soon on
their ideas or they're trying to do a
million different things at once right
if you're trying to create a course
same thing you have to build up enough
momentum you spend so much time making a
course creating the content filming
videos or writing instruction manuals or
creating the PDFs or whatever your
course structure is it takes so long to
make the course
and then you have to go and Market the
course and people don't know who you are
yet you don't have a brand yet so could
it work absolutely will it pay you more
than coaching yes absolutely most likely
it's way more easy to leverage that than
coaching
but again the timeline is so long
and most people quit too soon on it
where if you were coaching you can you
can make money right away as long as you
have something that can actually help
people right if you're good at what you
do you know how to solve somebody's
problem you can make money as a coach
right away and yes you're trading your
time for money but it's better than
having a job and it also gets you closer
to your customers at the very beginning
I'm much I'm a much bigger fan of
selling a service than a product because
it gets you closer to your customers you
get to know their problems you know
their issues you know what exactly
they're struggling with and you can help
them solve it which allows you to create
a better book a better course a better
product because you've worked with
enough people through the problem and so
most entrepreneurs fall into the
category I want to do all of it great I
want to be a speaker I want to be an
author I want to create my course I want
to create my book I want to be a coach I
want to do all of it awesome you have a
limited amount of time every week
to work on all five of those things at
the same time means there's very little
progress how if that's you and you've
been writing your book how long you've
been writing your book for
like when is it going to come out what
year
how many speaking gigs have you done in
the past three months
all right how much time has gone into
your course it's like we start and stop
and start and stop because we're
tackling so many different things
because you want to do it all and you
want to have income streams coming in
like crazy and there's nothing wrong
with that it's amazing but there's a
sequence
there's an order
that if you can as soon as possible
inside of your purpose
start to make money start to build
momentum start to be able to bring on
team to help you it's so much easier you
can go so much further you can go so
much faster you can have so much less
stress
you can have such a big impact
that you just need to focus
you just need to focus
it's all possible your big dreams are
possible
go in order figure out the sequence that
will start to get you paid
Focus if you want to go Brick by Brick
to make it stick you have to pay
attention to two critical pieces the
first is mindset the second is action
you need both or you're going to give up
on your goals you know you're capable of
something bigger but you'll give up
because you don't have these two simple
things settled out I'm going to show you
how to fix them in this video step
number one is mindset what you think
you're capable of is what you're
actually capable of if you think you can
go off and do it you're much more likely
to do it but if in your head no matter
how many skills and resources and people
are telling you you're great if in your
head you don't believe you can do it
guess what's gonna happen you're not
gonna do it and so you can apply Brick
by Brick in a methodology that I call
Big Y little y your Big Y is the big
reason why you're doing this thing why
are you doing this thing your purpose
comes in your pain you got a big goal
big ambition you want to change the
world you have a huge impact right you
want to solve giant problems and change
people's lives right that's your big why
you want to put a dent in the universe
right you wanna you wanna make an impact
that's beyond your life
it's a huge why I'm waking up trying to
solve the world's biggest problem I
don't think people believe in themselves
enough I'm trying to solve the world's
biggest problem I think that's the
world's biggest problem I'm never gonna
solve it even if I touch a billion
people I'm never gonna solve it that's
I think you should wake up and have a
big why so big that you're never going
to accomplish it you're going to climb
forever you're gonna be on your journey
forever forever forever it's the best
and oftentimes that big mission that big
Vision you have is so motivating for you
that it gets you out of bed gets you
motivated like let's go here's what I'm
trying to do and it gets you pumped up
but
sometimes the big picture is too big
sometimes your Big Y right is Big Y
little y sometimes the Big Y is so big
that you feel you can't do it
that you're not capable that you don't
have the skill sets that you'll never be
capable and so you throw in the towel
because it seems too big
and I get that too you know I'll look at
me and my goals of solving the world's
biggest problem and say who am I to
solved the world's biggest problem
right how how am I capable of going off
and doing that
and especially in my I'm trying to think
the last time I thought about that
especially in my earlier years as an
entrepreneur I really struggled with
that I I go do a speaking gig and and be
so fired up and so motivated like man I
know I'm crushing it I'm helping people
so much it's amazing this is this is
oxygen this is what I'm breathed is
amazing thank you so much
and then I wake up the next day and be
back to normal like oh can I do this I
don't know if I can do this because
there's lack of momentum and so that's
where the little y's come in and the
little why is the reminder that what you
do is important I think it's I think
it's so important that you feel that the
work that you do is important
if you woke up and felt every day the
work you do matters means something it's
having an impact man the commitment
level you're going to have is so much
greater than if you feel like nobody
cares what's the big deal meh okay so
how do you remind yourself that the work
you do on a daily basis is important to
at least one person that's the little
why the Big Y is a big Vision big dream
big big mission like where are you going
awesome the little lie is you may not be
able to help a billion people but you
can help one
just reminding yourself that you help
one person how I get that now is in my
YouTube comments even now as part of my
morning routine I go to my YouTube
comments and I just see what people are
are saying
and these are people that you you know
amazing people who many many of whom
I've never met and maybe never will meet
hopefully hopefully meet you come on my
tour meet me on tour probably I won't
meet most of you
and to see the warmth and the love and
the and the comments that you guys are
leaving makes me feel like this is why I
do it this is why it matters this work
matters if I stop doing this it would it
would mean something to people and they
you'd have to go somewhere else no not
so full of myself that you couldn't find
another solution but the work that I do
matters and your comments feed me every
day
I'm spoiled now that we get hundreds of
comments and tons of DMS and lots of
messages that come in Daily but when I
was first getting started
I didn't get that money when I talked
about my early days as a speaker I would
speak and have a great time and then the
next day wake up and feel like what's
the point I would say the thing that
made the difference was I would save the
messages that people sent me or emailed
me or said at the end of one of my
workshops and I would put them together
in a PowerPoint file and I would watch
that PowerPoint file every morning that
became part of my morning routine this
is when I really first started doing
morning routines this is this was such
an important piece for me was showing
the messages from these people as a
reminder every day that what I do makes
a difference and maybe I will never hit
my billion but these 18 people that I
helped I helped them that was me I did
that right if you felt like you helped
some people every single day
even if just remembering old people that
you helped every day as a reminder it'll
give you the ammunition the momentum the
fuel that you need to keep going every
day so Brick by Brick sometimes it's Big
Y right it's the mindset sometimes it's
the big why sometimes it's just man I'm
gonna go crush the world I'm so excited
I'm gonna go solve this giant problem
and and change Humanity right sometimes
you feel like that and it's amazing and
you go you go you use that boldness and
energy to create something amazing
and sometimes you're going to feel like
I can't do that big thing and so you
just look at the comments you look at
the the one person that you helped or
the five people that you helped or think
back the people that you have helped in
your life to remind yourself that you
are valuable that you make a difference
and the work you create is Meaningful
and to get the momentum and energy you
need because for the most part the
biggest thing you're missing is just
momentum and momentum comes from mindset
if you believe you can create great
things you can so Brick by Brick starts
with mindset Big Y and little y so I
said there were two things right there's
mindset and then there's action so step
number two is action so you you think
you can do something then you have to go
off and do it thinking it is not enough
you got to do something you got to act
on it and Brick by Brick here is we
often will plan this giant thing right
you have this bold Vision this big idea
amazing and you default into planning
mode and you think I gotta do this and
this and this and this and this and this
and this and this and this and it's
exciting and it's fulfilling it's
amazing to think in planning mode of
what you can potentially build but then
you step back and look at that Behemoth
that you just built in your head or on
paper and you think wow that's really
big
to do that I need I need venture capital
I need Partners I need I need I need a
team I need and all this all the stuff
that you need that you don't have
and then that becomes scary and then you
don't act and so I believe in what I
call the two percent difference the two
percent difference is as soon as you
come up with an idea
we're taking immediate action on the
first two percent so what we typically
do is we'll plan to get to 100 you'll
plan to 100 you'll plan your your entire
Vision out until it's complete right
then that becomes too scary instead of
planning as your first step plan is
important but it's not the first step
your first step is action your first
step is doing your first step is the
first two percent what is the first two
percent version so if your plan is to
build the next YouTube channel it's
gonna dominate the world I love it
it's easy to think well I need a camera
personally the team I need an editor and
I need a scriptwriter I need I need I
need I need anything great awesome two
percent difference take your phone make
a video today teach yourself to go from
idea to action idea to action the
smallest possible version that little
video you make from your phone what
difference is going to make not a lot in
terms of output but a ton in terms of
momentum a ton in terms of momentum most
people just don't start if you want to
lose weight you want to get in shape the
best thing you can do is do 10 push-ups
right now I had a person on one of my
Lives who said that their goal was to to
get in shape okay great
go do 10 push-ups right now don't don't
come back on into the live until you've
done 10 push-ups are those 10 push-ups
going to actually make that person lose
20 pounds of course not
but the difference between no push-ups
and 10 push-ups is the whole game
because if they do that 10 push-ups they
taught themselves to go from idea to
action idea to action idea to action
that's the thing that's missing for most
people you have great ideas I believe
you have Michael Jordan level Talent
that's something you're not acting
enough not in a big enough way not
consistently enough there's too much
time planning and thinking and over
analyzing and worrying about judgment
instead of just getting out there and
actually doing
so planning is important it's just not
the first step you burn all of your
boldness and creativity and energy on
the planning you wake up the next day
and you think I can't go do that big
scary crazy thing or instead as soon as
you get the idea the best thing you can
do with your energy with your boldness
with your confidence in that moment in
that idea that you just created is go do
something about it and teach yourself
that you're the kind of person who comes
up with great ideas who trust their
great ideas who doesn't over analyze
anymore and just puts them out into the
world and builds momentum that's going
Brick by Brick
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to watch another top 10 rules of
Evan Carmichael check out the video next
to me continue to believe I will see you
there why do you get depressed after you
accomplish a goal you celebrate a goal
for five minutes and then you're sad why
is that it's because you had the wrong
goal your goal should not be to climb to
the top of the mountain